do you find the struggle artist to rule
black women are so overlooked across
every walk of life I'm not anything I
wouldn't be right here if it weren't for
my sisters and we really wanted to live
exactly what those lyrics say and if I
don't have a transgendered woman or
diversity in my music video then sister
means nothing in a climate where it is
so hard for women I want to to be that
that voice for people that can't
necessarily use theirs yet to even be
heard because it's so hard out there
yeah and I know you're a part of the
Samantha bee segment there's so many
people that look like me that love
country music and that's what I'm here
to do we're really just paving our own
way what's the reaction that you've
gotten from being part of that well you
know there's a big majority a very
positive reaction yeah for so long that
was so scared to speak on these issues
because I didn't want to rock the boat
I didn't want to make anybody
uncomfortable and it made it in turn
like killed my spirit and this is one of
the first times that I was just like I'm
just gonna say it
I've just got to speak my truth and you
can't fault somebody for speaking their
truth and the truth will set you free
and anybody any pushback I bring it I
welcome it because it further proves my
point of how hard it is so I do get some
haters but it also sheds light on how
hard it is for us Mickey is also
passionate when it comes to equal play
for female artists on country radio do
you feel like there might be a ship or
people he's recognizing what how big of
a problem this is look this has been
going on for years even before I came to
Nashville and there's just this bubbling
frustration that we've had for so long
and it's popping and it feels like
there's a revolution on the verge of
happening like we are feeling so
empowered and it's just so cool that
there's people like you and and so many
men that want to be a part of this
that's all we're trying to do is to
bringing and shed light on what it's
happening and encourage people to want
to stand with us this isn't a battle
this isn't a fight it's just to get us
all to come together and fix the problem
I don't boys are - oh [ __ ] - I know it's
crazy it's crazy when she
[Music]
you build your up just let her down new
music what's happy yes with new music
well I have so much music coming some
very polarizing songs very it may make
some people upset it may not but it's
just representing my truth and what I've
gone through for the last eight years
and throughout my whole life and it's
it's truly gonna change a lot of
people's hearts
I believe that Vicki's new song black
like me was released on the heels of
George Floyd's death
you should try
it's not scary to think about putting
that beer yeah very very very scary but
I've gone through so much and I crawled
up out of the trenches and I'm so much
stronger for it
[Music]